Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba da da da.
Welcome back, Master and Mistress!
Hello everybody!
Welcome to Tokyo Jungle!
Every time I say this name, I think of... do you guys know Atarashii Gakko?
I say that as if they're not one of the most popular J-pop artists out there right now.
But I knew them before they were popular.
But they have a song called Tokyo Calling.
Yeah!
And so every time I think of Tokyo Jungle, I go, Tokyo Jungle!
Tokyo Jungle!
Hipster Mint.
Yeah.
I have pictures of me going to an event of theirs.
Well, it was a collaboration in...
It was...
I'm checking my Instagram.
It was in 2016.
I saw some people calling this Audio Jungle too.
That was so funny.
Audio Jungle.
But yeah.
Tokyo Jungle, a game that I know a little about.
I played a tiny bit a long time ago.
But excited to play it.
Because this game is only on here.
There's no way...
I think you can also play it on the Vita.
But...
Who's playing on the Vita?
Yeah, it's like...
So...
It's only here.
So you're seeing it here.
Everybody in 2024.
I feel like this game would be such a great thing to get.
Like a...
Like a remaster or something at least.
You know?
Vita...
Omega LOL.
Blast from the past.
I know.
This game is still on my PS3.
And if you were curious.
Which you probably weren't.
But I'm gonna tell you anyway.
Yes.
Metal Gear Solid 4 is the disc that's in my PS3 right now.
Um...
Yep.
I could switch at any time.
Where it belongs.
It'll never leave.
Yeah, it just kind of sits in there.
Being a good...
Being a good game.
Who would have guessed?
I know.
I'm shocked.
You should be.
Also Kyle.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you so much.
I do want to preface though.
Today will probably be a shorter stream.
Because I...
Have a late night meeting.
So...
Um...
I have to be awake.
And...
I'm not dying for that.
Can we switch now?
Switch?
Nintendo Switch?
No.
This is the PS3.
Um...
Shorter stream.
Because I'm not playing Metal Gear.
But it's funny.
Because I...
Have...
Um...
I think next week I have a couple longer streams planned.
My...
I don't know.
My schedule next week is still mostly undecided.
Um...
But I...
Have...
Uh...
Some stuff that might have popped up.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
But go up.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Outer Wilds is there.
Exactly.
So that...
That in of itself will be a longer stream.
I think Doom...
Is on Sunday.
That'll be a longer stream.
Um...
Metal Gear.
You know.
Yeah.
So...
Hmm.
Yep.
Does PSN still exist in PS3?
I've heard that both PSP series and PS3 is in PSN.
No longer there except for PS4 and PS5.
No, it is.
PSN is still there.
Because I literally...
I don't know.
I just bought a Metal Gear icon right before this.
And...
Yeah.
So...
It's still there.
A Metal Gear icon.
Is what I said.
Probably didn't hear me.
I bought a...
I bought an icon for my account.
It was 50 cents.
And then...
They had like a whole icon pack of MGS3, MGS2, and Peace Walker.
Yeah.
Money well spent.
So...
This is cute.
I'm happy.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's...
Press any button.
Oh, wait.
I think I talked for so long.
My...
Okay.
So...
Oh, I see.
Oh, I can't do story mode.
I was going to say, should I do survival or story mode, but I can't even do story mode.
Ryakari!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Oh, also, maybe I shouldn't start yet because I'm waiting for my food to finish.
I have a...
Actually, how much time is left?
Oh, I didn't set a timer.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
When did I put it in?
Uh...
It's probably fine.
Weird.
Usually, story is first.
Right?
Like, usually...
I wonder if you have to unlock stuff to then get the story.
Also, rare costumes and animal characters.
DLC.
There is one DLC that I know.
lol.
Shikanoko Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glow Glowthe Glutin.
Ryakari!
Thank you for another 10 gifted!
Thank you!
lol.
Story is, like, unlockables for specific animals.
Ah!
I see, I see.
What should we be?
We couldn't...
No, I think there are two at the very beginning.
I think there is a...
The dog and the deer.
Maybe we should be the shika-noko-noko-noko-koshi-tan-tan.
Daaarn!
Thanks for the thank you, dude!
Your streams make my days better.
Thank you!
Missile... well, we can always do both as well.
So, no worries.
Be the dog-dog.
Missile-minto.
So, we'll just chit-chat for a bit until...
until I remember if my food is done.
I'm gonna go check on it real quick.
Hold on, I'm getting worried.
Hold on, I'll be right...
I'll be right back.
Sorry.
Sorry that took so long.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I got a candy that I got in Japan.
Before.
Do you guys...
Do you guys wanna...
Okay, I haven't had this before.
It's a shio cider.
A salt... salt cider.
And I'm gonna try it.
Okay.
I'm nervous.
What if it's like...
What if it like pops in my mouth?
Okay.
The outside is...
is a powder.
Okay.
We can chat while we wait.
Immediately leaves.
Sorry.
It was like...
Okay.
I think it like needed like two minutes.
But I wasn't gonna come back and like sit for two minutes and then leave again.
I thought that would be silly.
So...
But it was like almost done.
I thought.
I think it's done.
I think...
Maybe I took it out a little bit early.
But that's okay.
Okay, here I go.
Thanks for the HAGS postcard I received in the mail today.
Thank you, Rob!
Oh my gosh, though.
I saw that so many...
I think at the post office, all the postcards were like destroyed.
I'm so sad by it, though.
Like it has this ugly looking like tire mark on top of it.
Like they got run over.
I think we were talking about that maybe...
If anybody wants a reprint, we can send those out.
But I would have to get them...
I would have to...
Maybe like we wouldn't have them signed.
But...
The mark goes right over your head on mine.
Yeah, that's how...
That's how...
Just a tire mark on your face.
Of course, it would be on my face.
I did all the work.
And it's on my face.
I so thought it's garbage and put it in the trash.
Divorce.
But yeah...
We're gonna do envelopes and stuff for the future too.
So that this doesn't happen.
We're really sorry.
It's a learning experience for us as well.
Okay, I'm gonna try this candy.
It's like really sour.
But...
It's fizzy.
Oh, it's fizzy.
It's already in my tongue.
Can you hear it?
Oh my god.
I can...
I can hear it in my ears but...
I think it's too difficult to hear on the mic.
When did you get to the inside?
Oh, I sneak a new copy in the next envelope.
Oh, true!
But like I said, it probably wouldn't be signed because it took us days to sign the other ones.
I don't know what's on the inside, though.
It's just a hard candy on the inside.
Did you sign them all off, Kai?
Yeah, we did!
So next time we meet up, we're probably gonna have to sign the next batch.
But I have to order all of them, so...
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Wow.
It's really hard.
Did you get your MGS Collector's Edition?
No!
They keep selling out!
You have to sign up for text...
or for, like, notifications for Wario 64.
But they text, or they send so many tweets.
Did you get Carpal Tunnel from signing all those cards?
No, actually, surprisingly, it didn't hurt so much.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the pink play!
Thank you!
I was a PSP during the old days.
You were a PSP!
How did you become sentient?
But never have PS3, because the games I wanted to play...
was Infamous 2.
Probably another PS3 game.
You know, it's Asura's Wrath, an Infamous series, also God of War.
But I played Patapon 2 and Monster Hunter Unite.
Nice!
Okay,
I eat my real food now.
Maybe I should have eaten my real food before having candy.
I don't like the inside.
I kind of like the fizz.
Because it made me feel things.
It made me feel a little funny.
It makes my tummy feel tickly.
I don't know if I like the crunchy part, though.
I'm 100% gonna frame it.
I got lucky in the ink smear.
It's only from Mata's eyebrows and above.
It's a very lovely card.
I did notice one thing, though.
This is 100% my fault.
I'm gonna put out an apology about it.
But I 100% forgot to include the artist's name.
And I didn't even realize until I was like...
I was taking a shower in Japan.
And I was in the shower and I was like...
Oh no!
And Matara was like, what's wrong?
And I was like, I forgot to put the illustrator's name on the postcard!
I was so upset with myself.
I was so mad.
So...
I'm gonna let the artist know.
And I'm also gonna put out an apology.
Because I feel really, really, really bad.
Oh, I feel so bad.
But...
If people ask for...
If we do reruns of them...
I can put the artist's name on the second one.
So...
Maybe we will just include them in the envelope.
Maybe that will be better.
Hmm...
Yeah, maybe.
But I was in such a rush to make them at all.
Because...
I had to make sure that they got done in time for Ofukai.
Okay.
Apology video.
I feel so bad though.
So...
Would it cost a lot more using envelopes?
I'm not sure.
But...
It's okay.
You know...
Again, it's a learning...
It's a learning...
And also...
I had...
Not to put...
Throw Matara under the bus.
But...
She did also double check them.
I said...
This is what the postcards look like.
What do you think?
And she said...
All good!
She didn't say anything either.
So...
Oh no!
Yeah, let's blame her!
Blame Matara-Khan!
Yeah!
Fire!
Witchcraft!
I mean...
Um...
Burn her at the stake!
That's what I meant to say.
I think the most annoying thing though...
Will be having to seal all the envelopes.
Because...
Like...
We'll have to stuff them.
And seal them.
Hmm...
That's the most annoying part.
Just checked and I got my postcard too!
Yippee!
I think the residue is from whatever machinery marks the postage is.
Okay.
I think so too.
Because...
All...
All the pictures that I've seen are very similar.
Like...
They all look like a tire scuff mark.
So an envelope should make things okay.
Luckily, most of the art is intact on mine.
Yay!
Actually...
At one of my jobs...
I was like...
At my data...
Data...
Um...
Entry...
Job that I had...
A long time ago...
I also stuffed envelopes.
Hmm...
When there was no...
Uh...
Data entry to enter...
I was stuffing envelopes.
So...
Truly...
I'm just...
Uh...
Returning back to my old...
Office worker life!
For real!
Or...
After life...
I guess.
Hmm...
Does it count as a life?
Even if I'm dead.
Hmm...
But I'm in my afterlife.
But it's an office worker life.
The office worker's not dead.
I don't know.
Ghost things are weird.
My un-life.
Sorry for eating.
I saw Sadoway do a spicy MGS3 cosplay on Twitter today.
My first thought was...
Would Mint like this cosplay?
I'm in this post.
But since it's of Eva, I guess not.
What do you mean I love Eva?
I love Eva.
I don't...
I...
The only person I dislike is Huey.
Even...
Even Naomi.
I like to make fun of her.
Mmm...
Huey deserved worse.
Yeah!
I'm so excited to play Metal Gear.
I feel like people might have expectations, and then the expectations will really heighten my anxiety.
And then,
people will be like, oh no, she's so bad.
And I'll be like, wait...
I mean, I've only played it a couple times, truly.
Like, I'm not an expert, but...
Expectations meant damn bad for snakes.
Expectations chaos.
I'm even more nervous about MGS2.
Oh gosh.
European extreme, no kill, no alarm run.
Are you excited for MGS3?
I'm not there yet, mentally.
I think I'm just... I'm so excited for Delta, I'm like, Delta!
I just want to see Minto have fun.
Yay!
Thank you.
You can get the brain rot hyperfixation without being good?
Yeah.
I mean, mostly, there's like a YouTube channel that plays 24 hour Metal Gear streams.
And like, maybe like, even when I don't have the sound on for it, it's on for like, a good majority of my day.
So I'm just always have it on in the background somewhere.
Or someplace.
I'm just... Is that your alt account?
Stop.
George.
Is that his name?
Honestly, I don't remember.
But... I just almost always have it on, so...
So, that's where, like, I'm always, like, if I'm like, thinking of Metal Gear, like, you know, rather than like, playing the games...
Um...
To satiate my brain rot, I'm on Mercari looking for stuff, and also, um, on that livestream.
Hmm...
Can you truly say you play Metal Gear Solid if you never got big boss rank?
I never got big boss rank.
Metal Gear Curious George.
Not Curious George.
I did that one time.
I dressed up as Curious George.
Did you guys know that?
And... So basically...
My friend... I had a friend who was really into, um...
Into, like, acting and stuff.
Like, he...
Uh... This was when I was in, like, elementary school.
And he, um...
He... He played... I remember he played...
One of the kids in Peter Pan.
But he was, like, really... Because of that, um...
He was one of the kids in a... In a college production...
Of Peter Pan.
And... So he knew this college well.
And their acting department.
No, not the Lost Boys.
It was one of the...
It was one of, like, the...
The children that goes to Neverland.
But, anyway...
They invited him.
That college invited him to dress up for...
I think it was either, like, an anniversary of Curious George or the birthday of Curious George.
Something.
And they were like, do you wanna dress up and do you wanna be the man in the yellow hat?
And I'm like... Thinking back now, I'm like, why?
Okay, hold on.
But, anyways... He asked me if I wanted to be Curious George.
But now I'm thinking, why did he ask me that?
Wait...
Why did he ask if I would be Curious George?
Why wasn't he Curious George?
Why did he think that of all of our friends...
I would be the best fit for Curious George?
Wait a second!
Fuck it!
It's so funny, too.
I don't talk to him anymore, but my mom still talks to his mom.
And she even mentioned him the other day.
She was like, I'm gonna go meet...
Do you remember that old friend you had in elementary school?
I'm gonna go meet his mom!
I'm gonna have her ask!
I'm gonna ask him!
Well, I'm not going.
But, I'm gonna have her ask him.
Why did you ask Mint to be Curious George?
But anyway...
I remember that day so well because...
Because I was like a menace.
I was throwing books.
I was climbing on tables.
I was harassing everybody in the library.
I was just like, I'm Curious George!
I don't know what Curious George is like at all.
I don't know.
But...
But I remember at one point I was climbing on the table.
And I either hit my funny bone or I hit something in my knee.
And my vision literally went black.
I like was seeing stars.
I was like, oh my god, this is it for Curious George.
Curious George's birthday and death days is the same day.
And I remember... I remember just like keeling over as Curious George being like...
I remember the day so well because I was in so much pain from that moment.
Oh god.
It's the trauma.
But I have to just remember.
I also... I got to take off a day of school for that... for that moment.
For my pain.
But it was worth it because I got to stand on tables.
Curious George ends up in the hospital a lot.
Oh no!
What if they thought it was real?
Like not a bit.
Or I mean, what if they thought it was a bit?
I mean...
What's a TBI?
I'm scared.
Maybe I shouldn't have read that out loud.
You really just have...
Oh wait.
You really have just always been like this.
What are you talking about?
Oh, a traumatic brain injury.
What?
I hit my leg.
It...
It transferred.
It was a full body concussion.
Yeah,
it's so much fun being Curious George.
Would do it again.
It made me think...
Like if I could be a character actor for like a theme park or something.
That'd probably be so fun.
To like...
I wanna be Donald Duck.
That was the day Min decided to become a Vtuber.
Honestly...
Until...
I saw...
The...
The auditions...
Like even when I saw Vtubers, I never thought about becoming a Vtuber.
But it wasn't until the auditions that I was like...
Like the Hololive...
Myth auditions that I was like...
I do kinda wanna become...
Maybe I can become a Vtuber.
So...
Yippee!
Love this game.
I'll be playing it.
Don't worry.
Sorry.
I'm eating dinner like really quickly.
Oh my god.
For like a half hour.
I'm so sorry you guys.
Crunch, crunch, munch.
Sorry.
One more bite.
Pre-game Zatsu.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Okay.
Oh!
I just realized you guys can't hear the notifications.
I'm so sorry.
I keep forgetting.
But congrats on your signature debut at Off Guy.
Thanks!
I managed to get a signed card from the Boston Challenge.
And it's so cute.
And I like comparing the slight variations with friends.
Stop!
Don't do that!
Don't compare them!
I forgot there was a big wave.
Blue soup was...
So...
Tea, but...
Thank you.
Yeah.
My signature changed over the weekend because I was like...
I had an idea for it and then it changed a little bit because of the postcards.
Even probably each postcard, it'll change a little bit.
I wonder who got the hee-hee card.
No, it was a...
It was a hee-hee sticker from the panel.
They probably threw it away.
Oh...
It's evolving.
What did it end up as?
It's pretty much the same.
There's just a little slight variation.
Mint.
Why was I the monkey?
Also mint.
So I was climbing on a table.
Don't think that, mint.
We weren't supposed to pass out the stickers actually.
Apparently a lot of...
Hey chat.
You notice how some of the signatures have different facial expressions?
Cute.
What was I saying?
Oh yeah.
At conventions, a lot of conventions don't allow stickers.
Even like...
Some conventions don't allow...
Artists to sell stickers in like the artist alley even.
But...
There's like a...
They're afraid that people will like stick them on like walls.
And stuff like that.
So...
When I gave it to the staff.
To Ofkai staff.
I was like...
Here I have some stickers.
For people that come to the panel.
And they were like...
Uh...
Um...
Well...
Uh...
I think they still passed them out though.
Did anybody who went to Ofkai and went to our panel...
Did you get a...
Did you get a sticker?
Please say yes.
Because I spent extra money on it.
I did?
I got both of them?
Yay!
Yeah, there was...
Mint ones and Matara ones.
Do they keep from selling stickers at artist alley or something?
Or just free stickers or a no-go?
I think it's...
You're not allowed to sell them either.
I think.
I just woke up.
Thanks for waiting specifically for me.
Before starting with.
You are so welcome.
Ok, now we can start everybody.
Sorry for the delay.
When I went to get a package at the post office the other day.
I pulled the Mata sticker from my wallet.
And sent my driver's license.
Oh my god.
Wait, why didn't you pull the mint sticker?
Why didn't you pull the mint sticker instead?
What?
Would you rather be Matar than Mint?
I didn't get it!
What do you mean I didn't get it?
RNG.
Oh, maybe they were random.
They were just kind of giving whoever.
The postcard is so cute!
Looking forward to the next one.
Thanks for bringing more eyes on the Tokyo Jungle.
I loved it and hope it will get re-released because I love the silly accessory in your art deck.
Oh, hold on.
Can I check?
And my art tag.
I'm checking.
I'm going to Twitter.
Silly accessory...
Oh my god.
The first thing I see is a Hawaiian t-shirt.
You guys, some things are not showing up in my...
When did you... When did you send it?
The accessory.
Oh wait.
I went to the wrong tag.
My bad.
Some things are not showing up in my... Oh my god.
Wait!
Stop!
This is so stupid!
Um...
Uh, sometimes I notice that things don't show up in my art tag.
Or like, I'll see things show up.
Like, as like a... You know how sometimes you get like, oh this is a related tweet.
But, um, it doesn't show up in my art tag.
Okay, I'm going to put it on later because...
Ah!
Oh gosh, that's why.
Oh god.
I'm going to mess up something with all my...
I'm working on a vertical monitor here, so...
Because my current... My other monitor is the game, so...
Ghost powers...
Oh god.
Sorry.
I messed up the, you know...
The...
Um...
You know, the way that you are able to view me.
Otherwise...
Otherwise, I would be...
I would be transparent, you know?
Okay!
Someone poorly explained this game to me.
You animal...
Survive...
Make baby.
Survive!
Run from crocodile.
Survive.
Survival!
Here we go, baby!
Hopefully it's...
Loud enough.
Humankind has vanished.
I'm kind of worried because I get really sad when animals get hurt.
A decade later, Tokyo's familiar landscape has become a home to beasts.
A jungle.
Pets have turned feral.
Wild animals have escaped from the zoo.
Oh my god, wait.
Is that a Matsuya?
For real?
Race horses have been freed from servitude.
Oh, my musubi!
You're free!
Let's take a look at this brave new natural order.
Uma-pyon!
Oh my god, that's me!
Tutorial missile!
Turn up the audio just a little bit.
Stealth?
Oh no.
Why is that step one?
If you hope to survive, do not allow stronger animals to see you.
Okay.
But he could smell me, right?
Oh, I'm just a little dog!
Tall grass offers vital cover.
The grass blocks other animals' lines of sight.
Oh, he's so cute!
Oh, oh!
Ah!
The tooth...
Do you think if ghosts count as human cotton?
No!
Leaving the grass will expose you!
I'm exposed!
Don't look!
The game would be too hard if they could also smell you, maybe.
Reach your destination using the grass to stay hidden.
Okay, the car.
This is just a tutorial, guys.
We're fine.
Can he see...
Can he see me, like...
This dog's blind!
Oh no!
The wolf's got sight of you!
Fail!
Okay.
He turned around so fast.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
Oh, he woke up!
He woke up!
Fall back asleep, buddy.
Okay.
We're gonna wait for them to turn around.
Turn around.
Nice.
Okay.
They won't see me now, right?
If I run?
Run!
Jump!
Oh!
Nope!
Pitiful Pomeranian.
I'm a cat!
Hunter!
Hunting!
Predators live by catching and eating other animals.
The hunger gauge shows your current hunger level.
Unless you eat, the hunger gauge will reach zero and you will begin to lose life!
If an animal's life reaches zero, it will die!
No!
Oh my god!
I know, this is just nature.
Look there!
A rabbit!
Approach it without being seen, then go in for the kill!
Oh my god!
I know, this is just nature!
Close on the rabbit without letting it see you.
Oh!
Once in striking distance, an icon will appear to indicate timing.
Press R1 the moment the bite icon turns red to large.
Strip your prey's bones and eat your fill!
Rules of nature!
Eat!
Oh my god!
I'm a dog!
Combat!
In the law of the jungle, animals must compete for food.
Odd!
Is that a hyena?
The scent of a fresh kill has drawn hyenas!
You can't deliver a killing bite while the enemy is watching you.
First you must create an opening.
Use the square button to claw and expose the hyena to attack.
End it with a bite?
Can I eat the hyena?
Dog go bongo, don't look!
Enemies will attempt to catch you in their own jaws.
If successful, the attack is fatal.
But if you evade it, they are exposed to counter attack.
When the bite icon appears over the beagle, evade, then counter!
How do I do that?
Oh, evade!
Ah!
Counter!
You eluded the hyena's jaws!
The hyena is left wide open.
Don't let this champ slip by!
Bite the hyena back!
CQC!
Even victors are rarely unscathed.
If the enemy has a pack, the danger rises.
Well, we'll have our own pack.
The hyena pack is just beyond.
Use claw and fang to claim their territory for your own!
Oh my god.
Defeat all the hyenas.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Two hyenas remain!
Ah!
Oh!
Evade!
Ah!
Yeah!
He's sniffing out.
He's sniffing me out.
I'm taking your territory, buddy!
Oh!
Ah!
Claw!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Don't kill me!
Claw!
I can claw you!
There we go.
Whoo!
Excellent.
My caution.
There's even a caution level?
Oh my god.
No way.
CQC!
You don't have to hide but are poor fighters as a result.
What the...
There's just mushrooms.
Plants grow in a wide variety of places.
The plant icon on your radar shows their position.
Okay.
I see it.
There's even a radar.
Is this just Metal Gear?
Eat three types of plants without being seen by predators.
Okay.
I'm hidden.
Metal Gear but with animals.
Eat!
Eat two more types of plants.
Okay.
I think there's only this guy over here so...
Eat!
I hope he doesn't see me though.
Don't see me.
Okay.
Good.
Don't see me.
I'm gonna turn...
Oh!
I just realized I'm kind of big so after the tutorial I'll make myself a little bit smaller.
So that you guys can see better.
Eat!
I ate everything.
One more...
What do you mean one more to go?
I ate it over there!
I ate it!
Make yourself bigger.
Run!
Oh, I didn't finish eating it.
Oh!
Eating grass.
Oh my god!
The hyena has seen you.
A sheikah deer stands no chance against a hyena.
Oh my god.
Run!
There.
A stand of tall grass.
Run for cover in the grass before the hyena catches you.
Go!
Danger 100!
Oh!
Oh my god.
If you can enter a stand of tall grass before predators get too close, you can lose them.
This dumb dog.
This guy is so stupid.
After losing sight of a prey, a predator will try to track them by scent.
If you are sufficiently far and hidden from view, your scent will fade.
The chance you'll be found decreases.
When the danger gauge drops to zero, the enemy will give up and move on.
Just a grass.
Just a...
It seems you've escaped with your life this time.
Oh my god.
This game is insane.
This deer is...
Oh, his little tail.
So cute.
This deer barely stood in the grass.
What a dumb dog.
Oh.
Breeding.
I'm a big dog.
At age 15, an animal's life approaches its end.
They must mate and reproduce or die out.
Oh my god.
I can't die without...
without...
breeding.
Before finding a female and mating, you must secure your own territory.
Four marking points exist throughout the Shibuya Station area.
Oh, we're in Shibuya?
Oh, I recognize it now!
Up there, where...
where the gauge is?
Isn't that where the...
Isn't that where...
the Starbucks is?
I think.
Use your radar to locate them.
Females?
I have a radar for females?
You can also see their precise locations by pressing start to view your map.
Mark each of these four points to claim Shibuya Station for your own.
Oh my god.
Female radar.
Hello?
Oh!
Marking.
Oh.
I'm peeing?
Hold on.
One second.
I am going to make myself smaller.
Okay.
Like here.
Hey.
What are you doing in my area?
Clean kill.
I'm not even hungry.
I just did that because I'm a psychopath.
I'm marking territories.
Where is another territory?
Oh, that's a bunny.
It's okay bunny, I'll let you live another day.
Is there anybody here?
I see them on the map.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I can't tell what's a bad animal and what's a good animal, you know?
Oh, I have a stamina meter!
Oh my god, I just realized.
I just realized I have a stamina meter.
Probably shouldn't just hop around then.
Over here.
See ya, hyena!
And yeah, I am gonna eat you.
Delicious.
Oh, I'm gonna eat you till I'm full.
Down to the boat!
Oh my god!
This game is real easy when you're a dog.
Okay, last one over here.
Go, dog, go!
Mark your territory!
Reclaim the females!
Oh!
Oh shoot.
It's okay, I got him.
Rodeo!
Herbivore is like hard mode, right?
The Shibuya Station lair is now yours to use!
Nice!
Yeah, where's the...
Oh, now we can breed!
She's in love with me!
Females have a arrived following the pheromone trail.
The females have arrived!
Come here.
Use the radar to locate a female and make her your partner.
Oh boy, I am.
The females have arrived!
Get out of here, bunny.
You don't wanna see what's gonna happen here.
Oh, the bunny wants to watch.
Never mind.
There are three grades of mate.
Prime, average, and desperate.
You guys, I'm desperately mating here, please.
Give me a chance.
I can't.
Oh god.
But the best females will only respond to males of a certain caliber.
Woo!
Perform hunts to raise your standing as a male.
Wait.
This golden retriever hasn't reached a sufficient rank to interest her.
Hunt down prey and feed to refine your skills as a male.
Well, lady, I have something cool to show you.
Come on, please.
I'm desperate.
You need to rank up to mate with that female.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Is that a sleeping cat?
Stop.
No, I'm gonna get Doki Bird over here.
Oh, shoot.
She's fast.
Okay.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I'm stupid.
Hey, hold on.
That's mine.
It's mine.
You.
Oh my god.
The cat's trying to get me.
One.
Oops.
They noticed me.
I'm so desperate.
Oh, I gotta eat it.
I gotta eat it.
That's right.
Yummy.
Excellent.
I'm gonna eat it to the veteran.
What does that mean?
Survival of the fittest.
This is just a game.
It's just a game.
Goodbye, Doki Bird.
I'm eating your body.
What else can we get?
Look at her just standing there.
Black buck.
She saw that, right?
She saw that?
Look, I'm just eating.
For the thrill of it.
I'm not even eating because I'm hungry.
Hey, am I good now?
I need to rank up still?
How much do I need to kill here?
These guys are fast.
Is that a chinchilla?
Stop.
Oh no, it's a bunny.
Oh my god.
There's more bunny.
Oh my god, the sheep are hard.
Is that a monkey?
I can eat the monkey?
No way.
Oh my god.
Is he gonna go...
Is he gonna attack me?
I can't jump high enough.
Maybe from here to here.
Dang.
Hold on.
I think I can make that.
Why can't I kill the birds?
Okay, never mind.
I give up.
What else is there?
Come back!
How far can you go?
Oh.
Hide here?
Hold on.
The deer are coming.
Maybe from the front of the truck.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
They're like, oh my god!
We just witnessed a murder!
I
think I'm good.
Seems you've reached a sufficient rank.
Try approaching the female again.
Hold on.
I'm not done eating.
What the?
I wanna get the monkey.
You live today, monkey.
Why am I so bad at this?
Hey, did you see that?
Did you see that?
Let's make babies now.
In front of these bones.
You met your partner.
The prime female is interested.
Head for your lair together.
Come on, girlie.
Wait, follow me.
I'll kill anything that stands in our way.
Ah!
Oh my god!
That sheep is attacking!
It's retaliating.
Is he still coming after us?
Oh, I think he is.
Uh oh.
Wait.
Where's our lair?
It's upstairs.
Oh my god!
Hey, don't hit my lady like that.
The sheep wants to join in.
You and me, baby.
I ain't nothing but mammals, so let's do it like they do on our Discovery Channel.
This is it.
Join your partner at your lair to mate.
This is so messed up.
After mating, you'll have pups, and generations will change.
Children inherit a portion of the skill their parents cultivated.
Mate with your partner in the lair, then change generations.
Come on!
Let's mate!
I'm about to die because I'm an old dog.
Please.
Oh god.
Birthday golden
retriever 2!
Happy birthday golden retriever 2!
Oh my gosh.
There's an elephant.
And a zebra.
Hunting.
Feeding.
Fleeing.
Mating.
These are the axe...
Fighting to survive is never easy, but only the victors live to see where the future leads.
It's the dawn of another day in the Tokyo jungle.
Are those... what kind of birds are those?
Those dinosaurs?
Okay, so about the R18 text...
Head
to the lair.
Hard to even know her.
Oh, I got a trophy.
Jungle baby.
I'm a jungle baby.
Oh, now we have story mode!
Oh, okay, okay.
What do you guys... I think maybe for the purpose of the stream, since it's not gonna be super duper long, maybe just survival would be best.
This is a real PS3?
Of course it is!
Survival unlock story.
I think story is in chapters.
Oh wait.
Story is really long.
Um...
Story is in short little snippets.
Okay, okay.
So it's in short snippets, but it's pretty long.
Maybe.
Mate first, story second.
Very, very short chapters early on.
Well, maybe we can try it then.
I'm kind of curious.
What kind of story mode could we have?
Mankind has vanished.
Leaving Tokyo overrun with animals fighting to survive.
Oh my gosh, it's Hachiko!
So it's the tutorial again?
Humankind.
Mankind has vanished.
Isn't this what we just saw?
This is what we just did.
Missile.
A decade later, Tokyo is familiar.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, so we have to do survival to unlock the story.
I thought...
Okay, I understand.
That was my mistake.
Hold on, let me get... I'll get us... I'll get us out of here.
Yes.
I just wanted to see missile again.
Okay, well then...
It's time for survival mode, baby.
New game.
Multiplayer!
Anybody want to play Tokyo Jungle with me?
Pomeranian.
Sheikah Deer.
Complete the Sheikah Deer challenge.
We got a little piggy!
Porcupine.
Ostrich!
Hippo challenge.
Now these are the DLC ones.
So you could be...
A red panda?
What is that?
Multiplayer mating.
Okay, never mind.
I do not want to play multiplayer with you.
The crocodile!
Maybe I should have bought those.
Instead of...
Maybe I should have bought those instead of him.
Look at his pants.
They're all dirty.
I like how there's the...
Alt color Pomeranian too.
And the dinosaurs!
Look, he can be a panda.
I don't think...
Pandas would live.
I'm gonna be honest.
Should we try it?
Wait, does that mean we can find a lady?
You think?
If we like...
Yeah, why is he...
An herbivore?
Wouldn't he be in...
Maybe he was... you guys... I don't know.
Maybe he was vegetarian.
I'm kind of curious.
I mean, I got him, so...
Oh my god.
That dog should be my pet.
I'm gonna claim...
I'm gonna claim this territory as my own.
Cocoa!
Oh,
he's gonna go!
Look at him, he's running over to his friend!
Oh my god, I got a trophy.
Don't!
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no.
We're fine.
We're chill.
We're cool.
This is Legend of Zelda!
Oh my god!
Yes!
Oh my god.
Danger 100%.
We can't let that dog see us.
Oh, we're hungry.
Oh.
And take 1200...
What was that?
Challenges are triggered by meeting certain conditions.
Completing a challenge will earn you special rewards.
Open the menu.
Have a look at challenges there.
We're a rookie.
Rookie gangster versus mob boss.
Okay, let's go eat some food.
You don't think the dog will like us, right?
Oh.
Survival points are a way of ranking your survival skills.
You'll earn points for hunting, ranking up, taking over territory, changing generations, completing challenges, and surviving.
Push your score to the limit and complete...
compete in the rankings.
Oh, okay.
Level 1 crook.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's it.
There's lots of food over here.
Eat!
UMAI!
Who's in the grass?
Gotta eat this chill.
UMAI!
This is so funny.
I'm gonna pee here.
ORE NO MON DA!
I love this guy.
So this is what an office job is like.
I've gotten 500!
Nice.
I'm killing it.
Two years!
Two year old!
What if I leave this area?
I'm kind of scared though.
He's thriving.
Okay.
There's something over here though.
There's nothing...
There's no grass to protect me.
So we gotta make sure it's not a crazy ant.
What is that?
I can't...
Is that a rabbit?
Maybe?
Oh my god, our hunger goes down so fast.
Why can't we get stuff out of the vending machines?
You know?
Oh my god.
Jungle 24!
What the hell?
There's a Fujisoba here!
No way!
They actually have Fujisoba!
That's so funny that they're able to like actually get the...
the actual store names and stuff for some of these places.
Whoa!
It's looking kind of grungy over here.
Oh, it's a dog.
He's protecting the area though.
I think I can attack him.
Oh shoot!
Ah!
Oh god.
Sorry, dog.
I gotta eat these apples.
I'm a little salary man.
Oh my!
Sorry, dog.
I can't even do anything with him.
It's so sad.
This is my territory.
I'm the most feral thing here.
Sorry, doggo.
Just don't think of it, guys.
Just don't think of it.
This is the rabbit, right?
There was something over here too.
Like, I wish I could move the...
Oh!
I wish I could move the camera.
To see like...
Let's go hide in the grass.
Then we can see what it is.
Oh!
I think it's a pack of dogs!
You guys, there's no way we'll survive this.
There's no way.
We can't...
Oh gosh.
A ferocious beast sighted you!
Oh!
Was sighted in Yoyogi Park.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Why is it so dark?
You will survive.
Let's stay the hell away from Yoyogi Park.
Oh, it's night time.
That makes sense.
This is my area.
This is my territory.
You're hungry?
Oh my gosh!
Salaryman, you just ate some apples!
Could you calm down?
You just ate some apples.
What am I hearing?
Life is decreasing!
Oh god!
Eat!
Come here!
I need a female, you guys.
He ate some apples last year.
Did you hear that, though?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get this dog.
Oh no!
Sorry, beagle.
Sorry, little beagle.
I'm hearing a lot of noises.
Oh my god!
This is terrifying!
What?
What the beagle do?
He was gonna attack me.
Probably.
When he wakes up.
I need more food.
Oh, drink water!
No, we have dysentery now.
Probably.
Six years?
We're killing it.
What's that triangle on the map?
That can't be healthy.
What is this?
Oh, that's the birds we killed earlier.
It's not funny, but you know.
What is that?
Oh, it's a chicken.
This is my mating spot.
This is where we will mate.
What are the yellow...
Wait a second.
Are the triangles ones that are...
that will attack us?
And then the circles are kind animals?
Maybe that's the case.
Or something.
I can't tell.
Oh.
Oh, it's elevation.
Ah, okay, okay.
Oh, I see it now.
Oh my god.
My life is decreasing due to hunger.
I need food.
Oh my gosh.
We need plants.
Like pronto.
Oh my god, my life is decreasing really fast.
Drink the water.
Oh my.
Eat.
Why are there so few plants?
Can you eat the chicken?
No.
Oh, we did it.
We did the challenge, everybody.
Let's go.
It's just corpses everywhere.
Hungrier than snake.
That's what I'm saying.
What's over here?
Whatever they are, they're asleep.
I'm just gonna take that then.
Oh, they're a bunch of bunnies.
What is this?
Okay.
Oh, present!
Zool Keeper Record.
Archives are records left behind by mankind.
Perhaps collecting them will offer some insight into humanity's sudden disappearance.
Open the menu and read more under archives.
I have to open the menu every time.
It's kind of annoying.
What's over here?
Chickens.
Get out of my way, chickens.
Where is any food?
We got the Shibuya Station nest.
Nice.
Where's my female?
Oh, ladies.
Eat the chicken?
I can't.
I'm an herbivore.
I can only eat grass.
This grass is not good enough, apparently.
This grass sucks.
You are hungry.
I know.
I know I'm hungry.
Just drink some water.
Drink some water.
Oh, my.
What about...
There was one more flag over here, though.
Wasn't there?
Hurry up.
Grow back.
It's been nine years.
The grass is still not grown back.
The nest?
Yeah, maybe our female is waiting there for us.
If there's no other humans, what do we...
What do we...
Who do we...
I have concerns, you guys.
I have concerns.
There's no grass here.
Oh, shit.
I think I might die.
No, no, no.
We must find more food.
Oh, no, you guys.
It doesn't show where any food is, which sucks.
Okay, there was...
There was that other area.
If I could...
I don't think I'm going to make it.
Can I drink this?
Oh, here.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, thank goodness, thank goodness.
It's just a little bit.
It's just a little bit to get us through.
I've survived ten years!
It was over here.
There was another area.
What the?
Defeat ten animals.
Oopsie.
Yeah, we're in Dogenzaka.
I think the dogs will...
Oh, they're gone.
Um...
Mine.
I need food, please.
Oh, God.
Okay, nice.
Any food?
Oh, no, you guys.
Food, food, food.
Thank God.
Oh, my God, there's food.
Umai.
Umai, umai, umai.
Good, good, good, good.
Good, good, good.
Okay, we ate all that we could.
Which wasn't so much, but...
Oh, God.
Did the dog see me?
I think the dog saw me.
I think I'm gonna take this spot.
Territory of Shibuya Woods is polluted.
Wait.
So is it dangerous to come here?
He can't breathe.
It's a cruel joke.
What?
No way!
It's like karaoke.
Oh, my God.
He's distracted.
Matsuya!
Is there food?
Present!
Bottled water!
Wait, are we gonna die at 15 years?
Use.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm gonna mark this spot.
Yeah!
We have another...
Where's my...
Leading lady?
Good night, world.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe I should have slept until morning.
Maybe I should...
Uh...
This is fine.
Probably.
Oh, God.
There's a planet here.
Where is it?
Oh, gosh!
It's really toxic here.
Then I gotta eat.
It's fine.
We'll be fine.
Grab the present.
Pet medicine?
What does this have to do with me?
Oh, it's toxic.
Oh, God!
It's really toxic here!
Oh, it's just sheep.
Oh, God!
It's so toxic!
Let's go to the other direction then, maybe.
Oh, this.
If we can get to...
There was like those other things.
Maybe the grass grew back.
Is Britney here?
Oh!
There's grass over here.
There's grass.
You guys, we'll live.
We'll live past 15.
I believe.
I believe!
Oh, my!
Okay, don't eat all...
Actually, you know what?
I am gonna top off.
Okay.
13 years.
You guys, we have to find a leading lady!
We have to find a lovely lady!
Oh, God.
Why is it so toxic here?
Wait, there was food and it disappeared!
No!
Food.
Listen, listen, listen.
Oh, my!
Where is our lady?
Why is it all toxic here all of a sudden?
This game is stressing me out.
Oh, it's toxic plants.
Uh-oh.
Don't eat that.
Um...
Do you think I'm safe here?
If I keep running?
I think it's okay.
Uh...
Where are ladies?
I know.
Females!
I'm in primating condition.
I've eaten so many plants.
I've...
I'm gonna have to eat it.
Oh.
Oh, no!
Oh, that really upped our toxicity.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like posting on twitter.com right now.
Oh, I feel like posting bad opinions on the internet!
Oh, good.
This one's not toxic.
Umai!
What are they?
Oh, they're chickens.
Oh, this area is like filled with food.
I should have come here from the very beginning.
What's wrong with me?
Also, there's like a lot of animals on second stories.
I wonder if it's all these crows.
You guys, are we about to die?
Can I... Oh, drink the water.
Can I go upstairs, I wonder?
Wizard status.
Look, we've survived 15 years!
What's up here, anyway?
Oh!
There's just a lion.
Maybe hide in the grass, man.
It's not worth it.
It's not worth the bite.
I don't think we'll survive against that.
Can you beat it?
I'm a human.
I can beat anything.
I took over this world.
I can do it again.
Umai!
Sorry.
Sorry, terrier.
I'm a beast.
Oh, my bad.
I still have that dog in me.
I've survived 16 years.
Piggies!
Um, hello, piggies.
We can share this together.
What other, um...
What other...
challenge list?
Mark 7 times.
Intake 2500 calories.
Head for the Yamanote Line East.
Hahaha!
Yamanote Line!
Uh...
Anything else over here?
No.
Let's go!
Oh, my God.
Look at me.
I'm insane.
Why is it so toxic here?
The accurate IRL mint walk for this office worker is a very nice...
Did you do the vocab for...
Shut the hell up!
Why is it so polluted here?
That's a cow!
You're fine.
We're friends.
I'm marking my territory.
Yeah, we're friends.
We're friends.
Umai!
Touch the cow.
Why do you have to be so toxic?
The tears of your lips.
I'm on a ride.
You're toxic!
There's more plants.
Oh, my gosh.
Get out of my way, pig.
I can see the plants on the radar, but...
Just some dead dogs.
Toxic plant.
Good plant.
Please, toxic.
Next karaoke.
Oh, my gosh.
You're like really...
pulling my leg here.
Oh, my goodness.
Just have...
Have to have me...
You're just like saying like... Oh, my gosh.
Minto, you don't think toxic?
I'm never gonna watch your streams again.
Oh, my gosh.
I guess I have to.
If I must.
Whoa, it's like really...
crazy around here.
What is that?
Oh, it's chicken.
Wait, why is the toxicity going up?
We're in a toxic area?
Uh-oh.
Don't get...
Don't get caught by the bagel.
Yeah, let's go.
Leave me alone.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
I think we're in trouble.
I think we're in trouble for real.
Oh, okay.
Get up.
Oh, God.
You guys are in trouble.
We're gonna go hide in the grass.
I just wanted to eat.
Visibility is decreased due to smog.
Uh-oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die here for real.
Okay, leave me alone, hyenas.
I'm just a little salary man.
Please.
It's so over.
No, please.
No.
Let me eat.
I just wanna eat.
They can't find me.
But I think I'm gonna die here first.
Did they just release their...
They just released...
That lion just like had...
The lion just spawned children and then unleashed them upon me.
Herbivore mode is so hard.
It's really hard.
I think we did pretty alright.
Generation change points.
Human is very hard.
High score!
New monthly personal record.
I got a world debut.
Wait, how do I...
Let me out of here.
Oh!
There I am.
I'm 898th this month.
There's over...
How many people are playing this game?
What?
How many people are playing this game a month?
That is actually so impressive.
This is so impressive.
I'm shocked!
And so many people are little pomeranians.
2k people, 896 bots.
Oh, wait.
2 people, 896 bots.
No!
I believe in Cryptid Zero.
They're a real person.
And Little Miss B123.
Um...
Hmm...
Uh-huh.
I just realized we didn't look at the...
the archives that we picked up.
But...
Can I still look at them...
like...
afterwards?
Ghost Bob!
I have to see who number one is, you guys.
Oh, wait!
Start goes to first.
Elvis!
900!
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait.
The point...
The point difference...
between...
No, no, no, no.
There's no way.
I think we have a hacker on our hands.
But also the Phantom Rice.
There's me!
Daily, I'm 83rd.
This is insanity!
Are you kidding me?
No, Phantom Rice is first!
That might as well be me.
They love playing as the dog.
Okay.
Um...
New game?
Imagine hacking the score in this game.
I know.
They're not even top daily.
There's no way.
That they're...
That they're that high for the month.
If they're not even the top for the day.
Yeah, we're gonna use the dog this time.
We're gonna be missile.
I actually think I'm okay at this game.
You can unlock other animals.
And you can also buy them as DLC.
So...
I'm a dog.
Look how cute I am.
Look at me.
Can I eat this?
No.
Okay.
So now...
Our goal is...
Rabbit.
We gotta eat now.
Defeat two animals.
Okay.
I'm not even hungry.
I'm just a psychopath.
Yeah!
I'm eating the crow!
I'm eating crow!
Let's mark this place as my territory.
So we can get a cute... Oh, wait.
So we can get a cute little lady.
This might deplete food stocks later though.
Maybe.
But...
What are these?
We're a dog now.
We have nothing to fear.
Not even this little tiny bird.
I can't wait to get...
Um...
Oh!
I pressed the wrong button.
Come here!
Come here, bunny!
Oh!
I need to eat!
Please!
Please come home!
Why...
Survive, rabbit!
Survive!
Not today.
Raise rank to veteran!
Raw Pomeranian right now.
Oh yeah.
I am crazy.
Look how high this dog can jump!
This dog's kind of crazy.
Look how cute he is.
He's so small and vicious.
I love that for him.
Alright, what we're trying to do is we gotta...
Well, first I'm gonna...
I'm gonna take this rabbit out.
Got that dog in him.
I think if anything, there might always be crows around here.
Maybe.
That's the hope at least, right?
Little chicks.
Always check the challenges.
Let's see what our challenge is.
Oh, raise rank to veteran.
We can do that.
Sorry, little chick.
You gotta go.
These poor guys are just trying to survive.
It's a doggy dog world out there.
Dogs gotta eat.
I gotta be faster.
Dogs gotta be...
Come on, come on, come on.
You were so close.
Run, run.
Let me mark this first.
Short legs.
They ran into each other.
Come here.
Little rabbit.
I gotta eat.
I'm gonna be hungry.
Clean kill.
Food is now easily perishable in the blister...
Oh, this is the blistering heat.
Oh!
We got a magazine.
My little doggy brain totally needed that.
Can confirm Pomeranians are just like that.
The song is good for bobbing my head.
Yeah.
We gotta get one more to be able to use the...
the mating.
And it's already almost four years.
You guys!
This is not good.
We gotta go to all the other side.
All the way to the other side of Cheerio.
We gotta start our generations.
Our life.
We have to mate.
I'm gonna eat this bunny.
Oh!
He noticed me.
Smart little guy, isn't he?
Where'd he go?
It would be funny if they hid in grass if I couldn't see them anymore.
For real.
If it was like...
exactly as it is.
As if the hunters are looking for me.
Dang, this bunny is fast.
Oh, they're coming back around.
Oh!
Our attack went up!
Nice!
Okay.
There's a lady.
You can now use the Cheerio station.
Hello!
Lady!
She's in love with me.
She's obsessed with me.
She wants to mate with me.
Who wouldn't?
Come on, mama.
Let's go have some pups.
Ara ara.
Are you guys ready for this?
I don't know if I'm ready for this.
Don't do it!
Look at all our little dogs!
Happy birthday, Pomeranian 2!
Form a pack.
In the event of your death, control will switch to a pack mate.
You can also order pack mates to fight by holding the triangle button.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, how do I switch to old dog?
You cannot use your parents' nest.
So I'm just a baby?
I'm just a little baby?
Baby?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I guess I thought the triangles...
Or I thought the little dots were something below.
But I guess it makes sense.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, yeah.
But I can't... Oh, next pack...
Next nest will have to save.
Who am I... Yeah, who am I mating with?
Wait a second...
Who am I?
Come on, guys!
Be faster!
Come on!
It's a doggy dog world!
With your pack.
No!
Maybe I should have gone the other way.
This way is really far.
Typically, it tends to be...
poisoned.
No!
We're gonna find another suitable lady.
Oh, good.
There's some food up here.
There's some...
Wait, what is that?
Is that a dog?
Uh-oh.
You guys, I don't know if we can take this guy on.
Do you think we can?
Oh, we killed a wolf!
It's too heavy to eat.
Or to lift.
What do you mean?
Just eat it!
What are you talking about?
Just...
Just eat it!
Oh, no.
No!
There's nothing else here!
I hear some crows, but...
I can't...
Oh, gosh.
I'm hungry.
Uh-oh.
Why is it so...
What?
Chomp him!
Chomp him down!
Yes!
Eat!
Eat him!
Eat him up!
It's a dog-eat-dog world!
What if that was the saying the whole time?
What's over here?
Oh, just little baby birds.
Come here.
Come here, chick.
I gotta eat you.
I'm sorry.
Chomp him down!
Oh!
We get...
A stamina jerky!
This is a cruel world.
It absolutely is.
Nothing down here, right?
Oh!
Okay.
We gotta be...
This is where the...
We're big dogs!
I just noticed we turned into big dogs!
Oh, wow.
There's a lot going on here.
There's monkeys.
Clean kill!
The monkeys are afraid of us, though.
Because we're...
We're so ferocious.
We're a ferocious little pack.
Yes, we are.
Oh my gosh.
They keep eating.
Hell yeah!
We got a flirty...
Costumes grant the wearer a variety of effects.
Anyone can just get by.
The top dog survives in style.
Change items through the menu screen.
No way!
Wait.
Items.
Flirty frames!
Sets heart athrob with these sexy spreads.
Missile!
You have me twirling my hair.
You're so flirty.
Wait.
What was that?
Again?
I think it was...
A click up, right?
Just skimming through will fills you with pep.
And then...
Halts stamina loss for a long while.
Nice!
Magazine!
Get out of here, monkeys!
Didn't even notice a thing.
This stupid goat.
You dumb goat.
You stupid goat.
Are you hungry or something?
Why are you standing so close to me?
This is my food.
Get your own kill.
Okay, we need to find...
Oh, it looks like it's down here.
The other...
Ooh.
Wait, where are we?
Just kidding.
I thought I knew where we were.
And in honesty, I have no idea.
Wait, where are we going?
We're trying to find...
Ah!
Oh, he ran away from us.
Yeah!
Get his ass!
Jackal!
I'm trying to...
You're in Tokyo.
Oh, thank you.
Why are a pack of Pomeranians so cute but terrifying?
I know.
Ah!
Good thing there's not fall damage in this.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to mark the rest of the area, but...
Hey there, monkeys.
Let's see.
Huh, maybe I do have to keep going.
The flag icon is on the map.
Yeah.
Is there a way to zoom in here?
No.
So...
I just have to keep going to the right then.
Never mind.
I was right the first time.
Head for Shibuya Shop District.
I'm letting him live because I don't want his pack to...
Triangle of Zoom?
Oh, you're so right.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, Shibuya Shop District?
It's so far!
There's an event in the Shibuya suburbs.
Maybe we should turn around.
Okay.
Let's turn around.
Before we go, though...
I'm taking this monkey down.
Sorry, guy.
Oh, no!
What are you talking about?
Why can't I just eat him?
Too heavy to lift my butt.
I mean, my butt's not that big.
But...
You get what I'm saying.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, no.
No, no.
It's too toxic.
Too toxic.
Toxicity is increasing!
We gotta get out of here, you guys.
There's no food here.
Uh-oh.
Am I gonna be in trouble?
Gosh.
Oh, no.
We're good.
Oh, shoot.
Come here.
Took him out.
We're eating him.
What?
Oh, my gosh.
What's wrong with us?
I'm just realizing now, too, how fast the hunger went for the human.
Like, our hunger is actually quite slow for the dog.
Oh, gosh.
But we're really in trouble.
What's down here?
Take the risk.
Oh, my gosh.
I missed him.
I missed...
Take the risk!
Come on!
Oh, shit.
I can't die here!
Please!
Let me eat you!
Uh, I think we're gonna die.
I think we're about to die.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no!
We went to dog...
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
Your death won't be in vain.
I'll eat your body.
Okay, never mind.
I can't eat him.
Even though he's my brother.
Let me eat my brother!
Let me eat him!
Eat him?
Eat?
Why won't you...
Oh, okay.
Why are we picking him up?
I'm marking.
There's the last mark!
Finally!
Oh, there we go.
Oh, we have to go, mate.
I see some...
I see some willing...
participants.
I can sometimes...
Oh, my gosh.
There we go.
Sometimes I gotta go in for the attack more so...
You know?
Nice.
We're a veteran, so...
I think the lovely ladies...
Oh, don't look at him.
Don't look at him.
Wait!
The desperate female.
Dirty animals, you!
Touch may pass you.
They are fleas.
Fleas itch so badly that you'll sometimes be paralyzed.
Bathe in some water or take medicine...
to get rid of them.
Oh, we have medicine.
Restore...
Oh, wait.
I have fleas!
This bitch!
You gave me fleas, you dirty dog!
I can't believe you!
This is what desperation...
happens.
This is...
Oh, my God.
Worth?
No, there's water right here.
We're okay.
Drink the water.
I have no longer have fleas.
Alright, desperate female.
Come on.
She wants me so bad.
I was wondering what the black heart...
I thought it meant she was gonna like...
I don't know.
I thought she was like a...
She was gonna break my heart or something.
You know?
Never settle, you guys.
What's this over here?
Oh, a rabbit.
No, we're gonna go make some babies.
Oh, shoot.
Where'd he go?
Can I eat this now?
Oh, nice!
Not nice!
Stop eating!
Hey, who are you?
Oh.
You wanna...
Oh, no.
I think this was the other dog.
I think this was the better dog.
We'll be fine.
Let's go eat some of these guys right here.
I think if I hold down... oh, that's when it's telling me...
Do you think my parents are okay?
I just realized.
I haven't seen them in a while.
Do you think my parents are alright?
Do I have to... I'm gonna first save.
Save the game, yes.
They probably died!
They're in dog heaven.
Is Mint a desperate?
No!
Oh.
Um...
A new archive has been added.
Continue.
Oh, it just took me out of the game.
That's so funny.
When I saved, it took me out of the game.
Save and quit.
Not just save.
No hard save.
Got it.
That's okay.
We're still mating.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
We are mating.
There we go.
Open up!
Oh my god, my brothers are watching.
My brothers are watching.
We have a baby!
Happy birthday, Pomeranian 3!
What's in the... what's in the...
Wait, there's only two of us.
Uh-oh.
The desperate female didn't produce enough.
What if I die?
There's only one of us then.
Wait, mom!
Wait, you guys need to make more!
You cannot use your parents' nest.
Okay.
What happened to my other brothers, though?
What happened to them?
Lower quality women give less babies.
No way.
This is so messed up.
Goodbye, parents!
I'll probably never see you again.
You'll probably be dead by the time I'm back here.
But, um...
Just wanted to say...
Thanks for...
Thanks for a good life, maybe.
Yeah.
Eat that rabbit.
Lessons have been learned.
Wait, are we already a big dog?
That was fast.
No, we're still small.
It's kind of hard to tell sometimes.
We're still tiny to pop, right?
Oh!
Hell yeah.
Why did you say open up?
Your heart!
Open up your heart to me!
So that we can make sweet love.
What are you talking about?
Oh, the heart.
Yes!
The heart!
What are you talking about?
Uh-oh.
Toxic here.
Now...
Poor guys.
They just...
They just wanted to be good.
Hey, where's my brother?
Okay.
What is that?
What is this?
Oh, it's like a bison or something.
A buffalo.
Oh, R1!
Oh, he's really agile.
Oh my God.
Uh-oh.
I think we're in trouble.
Holy cow!
Holy...
No, holy buffalo!
I think we're in trouble.
Let's get out of here, brother.
I thought I was going to kill him.
But I did not kill him.
We're still in 100% danger.
We're in less danger.
I'm going to mark this area.
Okay.
It's mine now.
We're in trouble.
This is my area.
This is...
This is my home.
This is not your home.
Oh gosh.
Oh my God.
Brother!
Brother,
I think we're in trouble.
Brother.
Brother, I think we must leave this place.
Never return.
Brother.
Brother, I thought we could kill the buffalo.
I thought we could just get his jugular and make it.
Why are you going the same speed as me?
I think we're in trouble.
Fail.
I'm trying to live.
I'm trying to survive.
There's no failing as long as I'm alive, bitch.
Oh no.
I'm about to die.
Brother!
It's up to you, brother.
Please.
Oh, the buffalo.
The buffalo.
The buffalo don't have beef with the brother though.
Our territory.
I think we're okay.
Oh, we're not.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Why did I come back?
Ghost trick time.
So true.
Load the save.
Wait.
Actually though.
I wonder if we should.
19,000 points.
That's going to put me in the leaderboards, baby.
High score.
You had to go back.
I wanted the territory.
Oh, it deletes it?
Seriously?
That's crazy.
Where am I at?
760.
Put me above Mr. Bios, come on.
Put me above.
I know we're tied but my name comes first in the alphabet.
This is so rude.
Asshols.
At least you're above asshawks.
Is it because he's a doctor?
I'm not a doctor.
Oh no, I really did delete it.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
What is multiplayer like?
Hello, Mint.
Love this game.
Was once top 4 for daily score.
Here's a tip.
Always go for high quality females as they have bigger litters, more lives, and the next gen inherits more stats.
Have fun.
Thank you, Arb.
I think I learned my lesson after our desperate female.
I think before I even realized she was desperate, it happened, you know?
What are the stats on the human?
I just realized.
Woo!
They're actually quite high.
Look at the different palm colors.
I want to be an elephant.
I want to be... I want to be...
Oh my gosh, what is it called?
Not an elephant.
The prehistoric.
What is it called?
Mammoth!
I want to be a mammoth.
Thank you.
This game also saves stats so you can breed lion hunting palms if you play enough.
What?
That's crazy.
I think all females are high quality, actually.
Mr. Uncle, you're so right.
You're so right.
How is there a mammoth?
Look, there's even dinosaurs.
Oh, wait.
Where are they?
Here!
There's even dino... Look at the speed!
Oh my god!
That's probably a velociraptor, right?
Holy cow!
The thing is crazy!
Oh my god!
Oh wait, maybe not.
Dino... not dino...
Dino... chungus.
The hippo seems pretty crazy, not gonna lie.
The hippo would be a formidable foe, I believe.
Dino chungus.
I wonder if we unlocked any story.
Let's check!
Story.
Not a single one.
Nope.
That's okay.
I'm very curious about the archives, actually.
We did collect some, right?
Zookeeper Record 1.
February 8th, 2027.
That's just a few years away, you guys.
The zoo animals have been restless recently.
The fierce predators are particularly on edge.
And fights are often breaking out between...
Between them!
Huh!
Feeding time has become quite frightening.
I think I'll talk to our vet about administering some tranquilizers.
Veterinary Report.
I've never seen the animals in such an agitated state while I've been at the zoo.
I don't know what could be causing this, but one theory is that they've ingested some sort of chemical that agitates them.
Making them turn much more savage than before.
Please check again to see if there's been any change to their diet.
That's it.
So was it the animals?
Did the animals sense something was happening?
Or was it the animals that caused human extinction?
To unlock story chapters, play Survival and collect the archives on the map.
You can see where they are by zooming out.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks, Jana.
Well, if we read them...
Did then we unlock it?
Nope.
Okay, we need more article... or more archives, it seems.
More archives, more archives.
But...
I'll be honest, guys.
I think I'm gonna call it here.
I know it's a really, really, really short stream.
But...
I said at the beginning of the stream that I have a meeting that I have to get ready for tonight.
It's kind of a late night meeting, so...
But this was a fun...
I definitely will want to revisit this.
I think I...
It's very interesting.
But...
So we'll play it again at some time.
It was a good...
Good introduction, rather.
Maybe I can buy some more animals.
To have for next time, too.
Would love a story mode playthrough.
Yeah, right!
Me too!
This is a really unique game.
It is!
It's so fun.
I like that it's...
It's...
Almost roguelike.
In that...
Like...
You have to...
You know...
Start over every time.
If you die.
Short, but it was a very fun stream.
Thank you.
Thanks, Gal!
Thank you, thank you.
This game looks weirdly addicting.
I know!
I can already...
Like, I already want to keep going.
But...
I'm gonna hold off.
Just because...
I think I've overworked myself a little bit.
And so I'm like...
I should rest a little bit, maybe.
Thanks so much for streaming!
This was hilarious.
Thank you!
Any games are roguelike if you keep hitting the restart button.
So true!
Try out other old PS3 games, maybe.
Many niche, unique games in the past.
And since I have my PS3...
The world is our oyster.
I can play whatever I want!
If I wanna...
I...
I've wanted to play this for some time.
Um...
So...
I'm glad that I can finally play it now.
Because...
Like I said...
You can only play it on the PS3.
So...
Thank you!
Have you heard about this game?
Oh!
Heard about this game.
But I've never seen it in action.
Looks really fun.
And a little brutal.
Have fun with Doki.
Tomorrow...
Yes!
Tomorrow I'm collabing with Doki!
We're playing a horror Kusouge.
So...
I'm excited about that.
Can't believe they never ported this to PS4.
I really like this game.
I really feel like this game could...
I wonder if it's the...
Uh...
If it's the trademark stuff.
For some of the businesses in...
In the game.
I wonder.
Um...
I don't know.
Hmm.
This game in MGS4 needs remasters.
So true.
It's on PlayStation Plus too.
I've played it on PS4.
I swear.
It's on PS4.
Oh, really?
Oh.
But maybe it's not as special as I thought it was.
Submit...
When will you make OG slash cover song?
I don't know.
Honestly?
I...
I have no confidence.
So...
I don't know.
I have some old...
Old...
Really old cover songs.
If you ever want to listen to some old cover songs.
They're...
They're like four years old.
But that's okay.
Um...
But maybe one day I'll have an original song.
Maybe if I have the confidence.
We'll see.
Have confidence.
A certain doggo.
Quoted by a certain doggo.
Yeah.
Um...
But we'll see.
Hmm...
Yeah.
So...
I'm sorry.
I feel...
I just realized that I only...
You know what?
Maybe I can play a little bit longer.
Because I feel like...
I only did like...
An hour and a half of gameplay.
Because I spent a half hour talking.
What...
What do you guys think?
One more run?
Should we do one more run?
No need to push yourself.
Fine.
If you don't want to watch me...
I'll do it.
I'll leave.
One more, one more, one more!
Instead of one more run, another 30 minutes of yapping.
Stop!
No, I want to play the game.
Should I try the deer though?
No, I think I'm gonna go with the dog.
Let's go with missile.
I changed my mind so quickly.
I made up my mind so easily.
One more ghost of it!
Thank you for the akasuma.
Thank you!
This time...
This time we won't mess it up.
Clean kill.
They don't know that I'm a predator.
She loves us but we hate her.
Okay.
Look at that.
Look at that turkey go.
And let's mark here.
Oh, there's a dog in here.
It's okay, I took him out.
This is my territory, other dog!
Turkey.
Yeah.
Flea shampoo!
Very good.
But we won't get fleas this time.
We're gonna find a lovely, lovely lady.
What is this?
What is the point of this part?
Like the scraps there.
I wonder.
What?
There's here?
Will this mark all of this area or no?
No, we still need one more.
Noise alert of...
I see, I see.
I can also jump!
Jumping doesn't even use stamina.
I'm gonna...
I think it even makes me faster.
Not so bad.
I'm gonna take a little sippy.
Oops, I always do that.
Okay nice.
Let's keep going.
Come on, let me eat you!
Come on, let me eat!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the cries are so sad!
The cries for help.
Actually, I think I just realized I need to level up.
We're still a rookie.
We're a level 1 crook.
We need to be higher.
Oh my god, the rabbits are so annoying!
My legs are too small!
Please, let me eat you!
Please!
Let me eat you!
I'm gonna get one of them.
Okay, nice.
I gotta dash?
Wait, how do I dash?
How do I dash?
Oh, I almost had him.
Uh-oh.
Is it this?
Oh, but it like... it like makes me stop for a second.
I got him.
No, no, no, no, no!
Eat, eat, eat!
Alright.
Did I do it?
Did I get all of the area?
Did I get all the flags?
Can you cancel... Can you jump cancel the lunge?
I'm not sure.
Oh, I ran past the last one.
That's why.
Here it is.
I think I was too preoccupied with food.
Okay.
Ladies!
Ladies, ladies, ladies.
I'm not a desperate male.
I'm just desperate for your love.
Ladies, ladies.
Please be clean.
Please be a good lady.
Bad lady!
Bad lady, bad lady.
Desperate, sad, sad lady.
I could smell her desperation from here.
Okay, we have to go all the way to the other side.
Before we do that though, we're gonna jump up here for some...
a little midnight snack.
Oh, wait!
Maybe now she'll be better because I'm a veteran.
Do you think?
Or is that not how that works?
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Sorry.
It's because the right side says sleep, but circle is on the right side.
You know?
That's what gets me about it.
Oh, shoot.
Why?
It should be... It should be...
The left side says sleep.
Well, that's... No, no, no, no.
But you pressed the right button.
So that's why I pressed the right button.
Instead... Or the left... Yeah, wait.
Huh?
Wait, huh?
I think it is a JP thing.
I think it is probably that.
I get it.
You don't have to explain.
Stop confusing me!
Okay.
Let's make sure this is a clean lady over here.
Going for the kill!
Oh, she... Oh, it makes you...
Okay, I'm gonna have to...
Yeah, you can't dash and jump.
That doesn't like...
Doesn't do anything.
It's okay, though.
Clean lady...
Excuse me?
Oh, she is... Oh, she is rejecting me!
You need to rank up to mate with that female!
Are you kidding me?
I was rejected.
Why?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
I'm
not cool enough.
I'm just a little pup, you guys.
She wants a real dog.
She wants a real...
A real ruffian.
Clean lady!
Kill!
Bow, bow!
Oh, my gosh.
How does she know how much I've killed anyway, you know?
This one is gonna be huge.
She's gonna be so impressed with this one.
It's so much calories.
I'm a fat pup.
I'm serving bacon.
We'll just keep going, I guess.
We'll mark this territory.
I want to go to the other area, but if the good dog...
If the better dog is over here, then it makes sense to stay over here.
Okay.
Peggy!
Oh.
This game gives me Xbox 360 arcade vibes in a good way.
It's actually quite addictive.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's actually very fun.
Karaoke-Kan.
Like...
Oh.
Mark two times.
Nice.
Oh.
Choo-choo-choo-choo.
Take over Shibuya Station.
Wait, didn't I not do that?
Didn't I take over Shibuya?
Oh my goodness.
Sort of like Day of the Diabler.
Oh my god.
Win over a mate.
I'm trying!
Please!
Wait.
There's a mate over here now.
Let's see if she's any good.
Oh.
No.
Don't touch her.
Stay away.
Stay away from me.
Stay away from me, dirty lady.
This pig is going crazy.
This pig.
Um.
Peggy.
Peggy, come home.
I need to stop lunging.
I need to start attacking.
No!
Stay away from me!
Stay away from me.
No!
You fiend!
Oh my god.
She's coming closer.
I can see her on the radar.
Desperate woman!
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run.
Oh my god.
Is that a cat?
Wait.
Where's another lady?
Oh many ladies.
Is she gone?
Oh my god.
Oh no, no.
She's still here.
Oh god, oh god.
I have to avoid her.
Avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid.
That's a clip for sure.
Okay.
Do you think we are good enough now?
Do you think she'll really like us now?
Pet medicine.
Nice.
Please.
Love me.
The average, the average female.
She's just an average female, you guys, but that's okay.
And here we thought you were the desperate woman.
No!
I jump, you jump.
That's how you know it's real love.
Yippee!
Uh-oh, wait, I need food.
Oh gosh, wait, hold on.
Hold on, ma'am.
May I interest you in a midnight... uh-oh.
Nice.
Okay, I'm better now.
Where's the other cat?
I think we're okay.
I think we can just leave.
I think we're fine.
Oh, cannot use the nest during combat.
Head for the... okay, here we go.
See?
Okay, so mate is on the left side, but I have to press the right button.
That's why it confused me.
Come here, come here.
Come here, average woman.
Average female.
Dog in zaka.
There's so many of us.
Goodbye, parents.
I'm just like in Pokmon.
I'm leaving the nest at seven years old.
Just like in Pokmon.
Alright.
Now, we go all the way to Shibuya.
Somewhere else.
Shibuya shopping.
Come on, brothers!
Les enfants terribles!
I'm the fastest of them.
Gang fight against the cats.
Oh, oh, hello?
What's happening?
Our dogs are supernatural.
They have magical powers.
Apparently.
The waiting thing to chat is so long, bro.
Hi, guys.
Hello!
Thanks for subscribing.
Sorry, I have to do that because sometimes there's like, you know, bots.
And stuff like that.
What's going on here?
Oh, I think this is a cat.
Maybe?
Or maybe...
Bunny.
We need to eat.
Oh!
Hello!
I'm hungry!
I know!
I'm eating!
I'm eating good!
Holy cow!
Nice.
Number one.
Number two.
Number three.
Nice.
Oh, uh oh.
Uh oh.
This is my territory.
This is dog territory.
This is...
Where did my brothers go?
What happened to them?
Oh, there they are.
Doesn't notice me.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
It's fine.
We're fine.
You ate them.
They ate my brothers.
Oh.
Attack,
brethren!
Oh, I don't like killing the kitties though.
It makes me so sad.
At least it's cats and not...
What was it?
I can't remember what it was before.
But there's a lot of cats here, you guys.
There are so many cats here.
Oh.
Nice.
No, it wasn't bee...
The water buffalo.
Yes, yes.
Those guys were crazy.
They were fast.
Oh my god.
The cats are going crazy.
Oh god.
Fight, dogs.
Fight.
Oh my god.
Fight, dogs.
Fight.
We can take them down.
Oh my god.
Yes.
We're stronger.
Oh my god.
Get through gang wars for real.
This turf is ours.
Uh-oh.
Our food is going bad.
Eat up, my brothers.
Before it goes bad.
Don't let the food spoil, please.
We worked really hard on this.
It's time to feast.
We will go from veteran to even higher.
We're not even hungry anymore.
We're just...
We're just insane.
I hear so many cats around.
I want to mate here.
I'm going to claim this territory.
Oh.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What's wrong?
Ah.
There we go.
Nice.
Hey.
These are really good cats.
Metal.
Poor cat.
I'm going to go pet.
I'm going to go love up my cats after this.
I'm going to go love on them so much.
More?
Oh my god.
It's an entire generation.
No.
This is our territory.
You guys.
Oh.
I think my head blocked it.
But I'm a boss now.
I claimed the cat's territory.
And I became the boss.
I'm a boss.
Oh my god.
Poor big boss.
Eat up my brothers.
And this is a lot.
And then we go find lovely ladies!
How much higher can I get than boss?
Can I get God?
Dog-o-heaven.
I bet this lady over here is really great.
Nope, never mind.
Leave me alone.
Stay away.
We're gonna go find a great, great...
Just down here.
Drink water.
No fleas for us, everybody.
No fleas for us.
Just down here anyway.
Clean kill.
Toxicity is increasing.
But we need to mate.
Do we want to mate in the toxic waste?
Oh my gosh, what if we mate in the toxic waste?
That looks to be an average female.
Okay, let's go to the nest.
Yeah!
Is it still toxic?
Drink some water, everybody.
Make sure we're hydrated.
Oh my god, there's just dead cat bodies everywhere.
Wait, I didn't kill those, did I?
Oh, there's more cats up here.
Uh, sorry!
Oh!
Oh my god, I thought I was about to die.
Wait, did we kill him?
Oh!
It's R1 to avoid, isn't it?
I thought so.
There was a lot of fighting...
Oh yeah, there was a lot of fighting, you're right.
All right, let's mate!
Good bye, boss status.
Yeah, right stick.
Yeah, yeah.
Happy birthday, Pomeranian5!
I've survived.
I'm done.
I have 20 years.
No!
That's where I was headed!
Aw man.
It's okay though.
So I guess you have a 20 year time limit.
Our parents fought for this land.
A.K.A.
me.
In another life.
Brothers, we must not take it for granted.
We will go to the shopping district anyway.
Territory of Yamanote Line East is polluted.
Where is that anyway?
Oh, Yoyogi Park has a lot of meat!
The suburbs and the shopping district don't have that much meat.
I guess we'll just check it out anyway.
Seems to be a lot going on here.
In terms of... there's like...
Wait, what was the challenge?
Sorry, I totally missed it.
Mark six times.
Intake 3,000 calories.
Find Bujin.
Reach Dogenzaka.
And find Bujin.
Wait, I have to go all the way back to Dogenzaka?
Are you kidding me?
You know what, screw it.
Oh wait, but I need food.
Uh oh.
I need food bad.
What is it?
Drink some water.
Drink some water!
Let's go find something to eat first.
Toxicity is increasing.
Uh oh.
You are hungry!
Uh oh!
Where's all the food?
Music is kind of bumping now.
I know, right?
Oh, that's not food.
That's a sign.
Uh oh.
I think we're in trouble.
Dog eat dog world.
Oh gosh!
I can't tell if there's nothing here or if it's low visibility.
Oh my god, we're gonna die.
We're gonna die!
The toxicity!
Okay, I think we gotta get out of here.
But there's no food.
Oh god.
This was a death trap.
Coming here was a death trap!
I think we're in trouble.
For real.
Drink water.
Our toxicity!
With
the taste of your lips, I'm on a run.
You're toxic.
I'm very hungry.
I'm gonna die here.
No!
Oh brother, your death will not be in vain.
We'll reach Dogenzaka, I promise.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, brother.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I have items.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay.
Oh, we had the bottled water the whole time.
No way.
Not us having it.
Using the bottled water and not using it at all.
Oopsie.
My parents are still up there alive and well.
They could have more children, but they just choose to make it really difficult on us.
It's okay.
We still have three lives.
I mean...
How does a dog open bottled water?
With his teeth, obviously.
Oh, what?
It's a toxic bird.
That bird is too much on... That bird is literally Twitter.
Oh, there's something over here.
I will eat.
Time to munch.
Oh, it's a bigger dog.
Oh my god.
Oh god, it's a big...
Let
me kill him.
Get his ass.
Brother.
Oh, our toxicity.
Brothers.
No.
Oh my god.
We've lost so many.
It's just us.
Now we're the desperate one.
We're the desperate one.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't realize he took two out.
We won, but at what cost?
That was rough.
That was really rough.
Get it?
Because it's a dog.
That was really rough.
Damn you, Retriever.
Our entire bloodline was almost wiped out from one dog.
Oh gosh.
Cracking jokes at her brother's funeral.
He would have wanted it this way.
He would have wanted it.
He loved jokes at his own expense.
So we have to find...
What was the guy's name?
I can't even remember.
Is this where all the monkeys are?
Okay, please.
You know what?
I might have to be the desperate dog and go for the desperate female.
I'm not gonna lie.
But I don't think we have very many...
Oh wait, that's an average.
No!
Come on.
Clean kill.
Oh, I got a pigeon.
Eat that pigeon.
Once they drop.
Wait.
This is perfect.
We can just farm.
We can just farm points.
We can just farm points here.
Just you wait.
Average female.
I've killed enough pigeons to...
To...
To really...
Impress you.
What if you brought a carcass to the mate?
What if she watches me?
Hello?
Let's bring it to her.
I have to rank up to be with this female.
Where did the pigeons go?
Did I kill all the pigeons?
The pigeons in Tokyo?
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Little chick.
Sorry, little chick.
You are now hungry.
Oh my god.
The pigeons wasn't enough.
The pigeons weren't enough.
I need more.
KFP.
It's okay.
They wanted this.
Is that a cat?
Oh my god.
Eating.
What time?
No.
We are okay for now.
Did we rank up yet?
Or...
No.
We are still a rookie.
These are rookie numbers.
Real.
What is this?
Oh.
There are the monkeys.
Come back, monkey.
Oh my god.
Monkeys.
Stop monkeying around.
I've got some balloons for you.
Come back.
I've got some banoos for you.
Where did you go?
Come back, little monkey.
Run, George.
Why are they so fast?
Okay.
We ranked up.
We are a veteran now.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go mate.
Nice.
Toxicity is increasing.
Oh gosh!
We're gonna mate in the rain.
In the toxic rain.
Toxic rain.
Come here.
Come here, yo.
How romantic.
It's like in every romance film when they make out in the rain.
That's literally us.
We're what everybody strives to be.
Like gosh, I want what they have.
Missile 5 and Missile 6.
I think I'm... I think I'm desensitized to it now.
Let's go, Pomeranian 6!
Survived 30 years, you guys.
This is crazy.
What is that?
A fat cat!
We're eating that fat cat!
Oh my god, no way.
Garfield real.
It's the day after his birthday, even.
So sad.
The...
What's it called?
The thunder is like so loud.
There's nothing here.
Nothing here.
Nothing here...
How am I supposed to raise my rank if...
Oh my god!
I didn't even see the hyena!
Holy shit!
Oh!
Ouch!
I was trying to...
Uh oh!
Time to fight everybody!
Don't eat him!
That's my food!
You bastards!
Oh my god...
That's my food!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
I got taken down!
Uh oh!
Shit!
My blood line is gonna take it down again!
Nice!
Am I all that's left?
Oh my god!
No, this is bad!
This is so bad!
The jackals!
I didn't even see that guy in the bushes, man.
And then it woke up the other guy.
But you know what?
We took out his family too.
The potato clan.
That was our highest score, I think.
That wasn't so bad.
That was our highest score.
An eye for an eye.
Dang, I really wanted to find whatever that other guy was.
We're fifty... five hundred and seventy second...
Okay.
Why is it...
You all have the same number of points.
Why are you in first, huh?
I'm five hundred and twenty-second.
I'm one hundred and forty-fifth.
What is that, dog?
I'm second, Daily!
Wait.
I'm so close to being first, Daily.
I am so close to being first, Daily.
RIP missile number six.
It was fun while it lasted.
Almost number one!
She's gonna go again, chat.
No, no, no.
That was it, that was it, that was it.
I think I'm good now, for real.
That was a good last run, I think.
That was a good last run.
Okay.
Dang.
I was trying to also find more of the, um...
Little things to unlock more stories, but...
More of the story, but...
My girlfriend Jess's birthday was this past Sunday and you're her favorite VTuber.
Can I get a happy birthday for her, please?
And thank you for this fun stream.
Thank you, Kuma!
Thank you!
Jess!
I'm sorry I missed your birthday, but...
Happy belated birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Jess!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay.
Alright guys, well...
At least we got further that last round than before.
This was so much fun.
I'm addicted to this game, for real.
I want to keep playing.
Maybe I'll have to do a really long stream of this.
90% of survivors quit before making number one.
I'm a quitter!
Also, you went the wrong direction for the story.
Oh, was it only in the Shibuya area that I could get it?
The Shibuya shopping district?
But it was so toxic there.
I was going to die out, so...
That's okay, though.
I had a lot of fun watching you today.
Thank you!
I have work tomorrow during your stream, so I hope you have a lot of fun then, too.
Good luck with work, Genki!
Thank you so much for the super time.
Thank you, guys!
So yeah, I'm going to head out now.
Otsu minto!
Otsu...
Otsu Boston.
Otsu minto.
Have a great rest of your night, or a great day, whatever time it is for you!
Itterashai!
Master!
Lady!
Bye bye!
Thank you for watching!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
Bye bye!